foreign
what's the difference between speaking
and public speaking
because the more we study it the more we
realize the difference is mostly in your
mind
the stakes the pressure how we treat the
audience so everyone has a different
relationship to it
but what we've noticed that's most
interesting to us is that people already
speak really well in the right context
with their friends
when you're at home and you've had a
couple beers like we already have those
skills and yet something changes when
the pressure Rises and Ultra speaking is
the study of what those changes are and
how can we return back to this feeling
of normality this feeling of ease
because if the root of it speaking is so
fun it's like dancing it's like drawing
it's like surfing it's a flow-based
activity and so Ultra speaking began as
this research project and now it's a
school it's a community of people
learning how to improve their speaking
skills and everything comes back to what
is the root of communication how can we
go back to that human to human Flow
State of conversation and how can we
access that in moments that feel
difficult or pressure